oui oui en tout cas c'est un film die
c'est une comédie d'action donc jouée
par deux audio de deux garçons donc oui
on peut dire que il ya déjà des flingues
ça tire dans tous les sens et les
courses poursuites c'est ça aussi c'est
peut-être un peu plus à un film de mecs
qu'un film de là bas c'est possible
ouais je crois que ça sert dans ce
métier toute façon et puis dans la vie
fin
oui j'ai une grande gueule en tout cas
je ne me laisse pas faire et marcher
dessus
donc je sais être plutôt doux c'est cool
quand il faut mais si on m'embête est il
qu'on bouscule je sais et répondre aussi
en bousculant sans la pampa [ __ ]
d'accord ok cash piste pour moi j'adore
qu'on tourne au salon guiche aux
tournées bullish
tu m'as pris mon kit à couvrir en direct
us étaient mulisha j'ai eu l'image et
l'image
oui et non en fait je me suis inspiré
des parce que il ya un côté un peu
cliché chez ces chanteuses là on peut
vite voilà on peut vite jouer ce
personnage là en lui donnant de trois
aspects et physique et et voilà est là
elle a une grande gueule pour le coup
elle se laisse pas marcher dessus c'est
une nana qui a grandi dans une cité un
peu dur et en même temps qui acquit
joutes sont ultra féminité donc voilà
fallait il fallait jouer tout ça donc je
me suis un petit peu inspiré mais on a
essayé de créer un vrai personnage aussi
pas forcément qu'ils ressemblent pas
forcément non plus à une chanteuse en
particulier on voulait pas singer et
puis ça n'aurait pas été forcément sympa
pour les chanteuses en question
j'allais jour benjamine de la police
bonjour à jour elle s'en sort on les
charge et de protection jusqu'à cannes
par l'ensemble mais avec nous vous êtes
en face on va vous souhaitez ça vous
avez fait vos voyages je n'ai pas eu
trop de temps bull super marrant qui se
dégonfle et de guerre à cause de blanca
lui